the babylonian king Hammurabi was
responsible for establishing the
earliest known law code now probably
other rulers and States must have had
sets of laws but it's Hammurabi's code
of laws that's the earliest coherent
system that survives so he gets the
credit for it law codes are absolutely
vital if one is to have large cities
when you're in a little cell a
settlement or a village it's possible in
fact is is usually the common practice
for interpersonal disputes to be handled
by family elders and that kind of system
usually works because in these small
environments everybody knows everybody
else or at least is bound by some sort
of extended kinship tie but once you
start to have cities real urban centers
with big populations you end up with a
large number of strangers living and
interacting with one another in those
circumstances conflicts among
individuals inevitably arise and you
need to have some way that you can
mediate those in a relatively impartial
manner otherwise you would just have
chaos and you have people killing one
another and that is the great
contribution of law codes it provides a
set of rules to impersonally adjudicate
these disputes and to resolve them and
by doing so it makes big cities possible
now if you look at Hammurabi's law code
from a modern perspective admittedly
aspects of it might seem a bit harsh and
really unfair for example the prescribed
punishment for almost any offense is
death and all human beings in
Hammurabi's law code are most certainly
not treated equally so there are
different rules and punishments for
groups such as women the poor and slaves
in general Hammurabi's law code falls
into a category of law codes which are
termed retaliatory and what this means
is that what you do to someone else
typically gets done to you in return
many of the rules of the Old Testament
which was also formulated in the ancient
Near East during a second millennium BC
are of a similar retaliatory nature and
this is exemplified by the familiar
phrase an eye for an eye a tooth for a
tooth
that's a retaliatory law code at times
this reciprocal approach of Hammurabi's
code leads to some very creative
punishments so for example when a person
is discovered stealing from a burning
house the punishment is he himself is
condemned to be thrown into a fire or
when a doctor is botched in operation he
is then sentenced to have his hands
chopped off at other times the code
seems almost surprisingly sympathetic to
groups who often are marginalized in
these societies for example there's a
law in Hammurabi's code that prescribes
that if a man divorces his wife and
she's borne him a child
he must not only return her dowry but
also has to provide additional financial
support for raising the child and
whatever it's quirks
Hammurabi's code really represents a
huge step forward for all of
civilization because it makes it
possible for large numbers of people to
live in cities
you